I got a lot of questions so let's try to
get through it uh how did you decide on
Eight Episodes was it you guys or the
studio it was us and it was actually
kind of arbitrary we we threw it out
there and I'm thank God we didn't throw
out 10 because we probably would have
died
um you guys I saw the four of the Eight
Episodes already and I believe you wrote
and directed the four that I saw did you
do the whole season uh we did we did
half the season so the four that I saw
yeah but we were the show Runners so we
were involved in all of it but we did no
the first three that you saw and then
the last one of the season so we did uh
one two three and eight good that was
paying attention clearly I thought you
did the first four one of the things
about the series how much and I think I
mentioned this to you yesterday when you
were going into pitch and you know
present the network on doing this how
much they want to know you have a
multiple season plan and how much was it
sort of like let's just make a good
first season then we'll talk later oh
they were really great about just
trusting us uh you know we we saw we
we had to figure out the whole season
just to write the first episode which we
expect just about to sell uh so we'd
pitched that immediately out the bat and
asked for the order so
we were asked if we thought it was a
multi-season show and we said yeah
absolutely because this is sort of a
creation myth of a bunch of characters
that are going to go on to do other
things uh but we'll always also be
looking at the past so I I think we have
no kind of shortage of uh
of uh real estate I think so one of the
things about the series is that you're
not it keeps the audience on its toes
because you're not sure who is on whose
side and can you sort of talk about
um when and where you wanted to release
information about characters over the
course of the Eight Episodes and how did
that possibly change as a result in the
editing room uh it didn't change in the
editing room we you know we wrote all
eight of the scripts before we shot
anything so we knew what the story was
going to be and we we really had to
stick to uh you know what we planned to
do because it was we and we we said when
we sold the show like we want to do all
eight we want to pick up for all eight
or we're not gonna do the show because
because we're just like this is not the
kind of show you can write one and then
write another and write another and then
that's you know the audience would be
furious because things wouldn't tie
together so we want a whole season we
want to write the whole season and we
want to plant Easter eggs and plot lines
and characters that you know we'll be
following story lines and characters
that won't pay off until episode eight
and and we want the audience to be able
to go like oh okay well that's what that
was what you know that was like
aggravating me all season long
and now I know that's what this is you
know and that that sort of thing it's
like and then to have that sort of fun
puzzle quality to the show uh for the
audience we just wanted to like bring
them in and and we want people to like
uh put their phones down and pay
attention and you know have a one screen
experience
I completely understand what you're
saying yeah the show depicts private
Espionage and I'm curious how much do
you think of what you're showing on the
series is actually happening in in real
life we researched there's a there's a
couple of firms on Wall Street
I'm not gonna say they do exactly what
John Weir does we definitely took
Liberties but uh they they do do uh
Intel and
um disinformation to uh
as a consultancy you know they'll
they'll run they'll run uh research uh
the name of the Apple research one of
the firms is called Muddy Waters yeah
I mean they're like they're not
hiding they're not shy about it they're
like they they go and they just muddy
the water and they they create like
questions about stocks and it's like you
know this is real I mean that's real and
then as the show goes along you get into
the sort of the real Espionage about the
government and corporations hacking into
our data and that's all shockingly real
I mean you know we had to turn it turn
it up because you want to dramatize it
you know you're turning it up it's like
it's just the truth yeah it's I try
explaining to people that anything that
you um put in an email anything you text
anything you do online any credit card
you use you're basically as you depict
in the show they're forming a profile on
you and they know everything they know
everything about you before you probably
even realize you're going to do it even
even if your data is so called cure or
private
um as much as that can be done
that data that Cambridge analytica used
was Private it was for educational
purposes and it was taken and used to
form
profiles and research and and uh and
strategy and
you know
privacy is it's not you know it's it's
more of a handshake you know no
completely Also let's be honest if you
use a credit card everything you're
buying is being tracked so you're just
giving it all up there you know in this
day and age of
um there's a lot of Television out there
and a lot of options for people on what
to watch and I usually don't ask this
but I'm going to ask you guys what is it
about the series that you want to sort
of tell people this is why you should
watch the show I think it's just really
engaging and fun and you know trying to
figure it out is is
part of the fun and like John was saying
the one screen experience you know like
a lot of shows you can kind of listen to
while you're doing something else and
and that's fine there's nothing wrong
with that but we really wanted to do a
show where you better like
you know it's a puzzle and I have fun
with it yeah we wanted to engage the
audience we didn't want to insult their
intelligence we wanted to make have a
show that's full of Hidden Truths and
surprises that they can either get ahead
of or miss it and and have part of and
and join us in that kind of game it's
you know it's a game and David Fincher
is a game is a big influence on this the
game is um I'm gonna use this let me
think about the right word oh it's kind
of amazing yeah it's it's some I don't
know I mean and it just holds up that's
the thing that's amazing it's just like
it's As Good As It Ever Was I've said
this a number of times I'll say it to
you guys I think every Fincher release
should be a national holiday I I agree
like he he is phenomenal it is crazy
hair into it it shows and he doesn't
insult his audience no he he thinks
they're intelligent and he tells smart
stories you know yeah phenomenal
filmmaker before I run out of time with
the two of you I think you probably know
what's coming now you guys worked on
what we call Bad Santa
yeah which um as you know I saw the
original cut way back when lost my mind
lost my mind watching that first cut
um you mentioned yesterday when we were
talking and I had no idea that Mickey
Rooney Mickey Rooney auditioned for the
movie yeah you auditioned to play Marcus
the dwarf or the elf I'm sorry uh and uh
he famously there was a videotape that
Terry zweigoff has yeah we're doing
enough we're doing another project uh
we're going on the town with Terry we're
going to do another project with Terry
uh this amazing series that he wrote
about record collecting and uh about
shellac records and he it's amazing
we're gonna go out on the town with that
now but so but he and we're hoping we're
doing we want to talk about this because
we want Terry to dig into his closet
because there's a VHS of Mickey Rooney
auditioning as Marcus because the whole
thing is is that Mickey Rooney he'd be
doing the scenes and you know the
profanity it's like was the at the time
it was the most F words in any movie and
Mickey Rooney would be doing the scene
and he would like the time would come up
for him to say he would he would
just go and pause and then he would go
on and then another like a he pause
and he would go on and then Terry said
to him he said Mickey why aren't you
saying the dialogue he goes there's a
lady Pleasant present I don't do it on
the day I'll do it on the day but for
now for now because there's a lady
president
because there won't be any ladies on the
set I guess yeah because he's old
Hollywood did he come close to getting
the role or no I have no idea I don't
think he did I think it was a bridge
my favorite thing we showed up on one of
the one of the shooting days of bad
Santa and we saw um uh uh you know
Marcus uh Tony Cox any you know he's
African-American and he had the little
white Caucasian ear elf tips
like this is my genius moment oh and by
the way
um the uh
what was he oh
what's the other great one the Marcus
story
um lipstick one little fist up your ass
no no no no no oh we were when Joel and
Ethan were pitching us the idea to go uh
we're out to dinner with Joel and Ethan
and they said we have this idea for a
movie called Bad Santa he drinks beer
and stuff that was the film Stitch and
that and then and then we said okay
while we have this Robert Westlake
that we're obsessed with so we're gonna
we think we can turn that bad santa into
like a Robert Westlake Donald Trump
Donald Wesley Donald was like a movie
and and so we went off and and but then
during dinner we were drinking wine and
having a good time and they started
telling stories about the little person
who was on Oh Brother Where Art Thou and
was it old brother yeah I think yeah and
he was like a complete dick
and he was like he would talk to the
producers like why do you put me on the
25th floor I can't reach the 25th button
you know he was just like a complete
dick and we're like oh well that's going
in the movie
[Laughter]
um I gotta stop here I'm just gonna say
uh gentlemen I hope this series is a
huge hit for you guys oh thanks and uh I
wish you nothing but the best